more than two years after
January 6 the worst day in this
world two years later House Republicans
have finally obtained security camera
footage of what actually happened in the
capital that day the Republicans got the
footage they gave it to Tucker Carlson
and his producers to investigate and
release and Congressional Democrats are
not happy about it
last night millions of Americans tuned
into one of the most shameful hours we
have ever seen on cable television
with contempt for the facts
disregarded the risks
and knowing full well he was lying lying
to his audience
Fox News host Tucker Carlson ran a
lengthy segment last night arguing the
January 6 Capital attack
was not a violent insurrection
by diving deep into the Waters of
conspiracy and cherry picking from
thousands of hours of security footage
Mr Carlson told the bold-faced lie that
the capital attack which we all saw with
their own eyes
was somehow not an attack at all and
he's going to come back tonight with
another segment
Fox News should tell him not to
Fox News Rupert Murdoch tell Carlson not
to run a second segment of Lies you know
it's a lie you've admitted it's a lie
do not play the clips the videos are a
lie pay no attention to the man behind
the curtain who are you going to believe
Chuck Schumer or your own Lying Eyes the
Liberals are not very happy they're
they're having a very angry week they're
losing it they're calling everybody
Nazis they're saying this is the end of
the world the end of democracy the end
of the Republic not just because some
people think men and women are different
but also because some people want to see
the footage from January 6th we were
told that January 6th was the greatest
Insurrection the worst nearer coup
d'etat in the history of the world and
we've only seen little clips of the
footage
little clips that the establishment
press are willing to let us see the
little clips that the Democrats in
Congress when they had control of
Congress allowed us to look at and I
made this point on the show just a few
days ago I said when you read a news
story the first question that you ask
should not be about the details of the
story itself the first question you
should ask is why is this story being
presented to me and why is it being
presented to me right now
that's the that's the meta news
metapolitical question that you've got
to ask Chuck Schumer said in his remarks
begging Fox News please don't let Tucker
play the tape that proves this all to be
Liars Chuck Schumer said we all saw the
Insurrection no we didn't all see the
insurrection
all we saw was a handful of clips that
you Democrats curated very specifically
to give the impression that January 6th
was the worst coup d'etat ever
now
now that the Republicans took charge of
the Congress
Kevin McCarthy has access to that
footage and he released 41 000 hours of
it to Tucker Carlson and Tucker
Carlson's investigators have gone
through that footage and now they're
presenting us with a fuller picture and
the Fuller picture shows that what we
were told simply was not true
up to and including
the Q Anon Shaman you know the guy with
the the horn hat painted face screaming
yellow he was he was the the king he was
the one who was going to declare himself
King tear up the Constitution create a
new government right that was what was
supposed to happen Well turns out that
guy
was escorted through the capital
by Capitol Police Jacob chansley became
the face of January 6th a dangerous
conspiracy theorist dressed in
outlandish costume who led the violent
Insurrection to overthrow American
democracy for these crimes chansley was
sentenced to nearly four years in prison
far more time than many violent
criminals now receive what did Jacob
chansley do to receive this punishment
to this day there is dispute over how
chansley got into the Capitol building
but according to our review of the
internal surveillance video it is very
clear what happened once he got inside
virtually every moment of his time
inside the capital was caught on tape
the tape show that Capitol Police never
stopped Jacob chansley they helped him
they acted as his tour guides here's
video of chansley in the Senate chamber
Capitol police officers take him to
multiple entrances and even try to open
locked doors for him
we counted at least nine officers who
were within touching distance of unarmed
Jacob chansley not one of them even
tried to slow him down
it doesn't look like an Insurrection to
me
the images that you were presented with
was of of a guy leading a crusade a
violent mob that was killing police
officers remember they told you that
they told you they killed police
officers that was a complete lie only
one person died in political violence on
January 6 that was Ashley Babbitt that
was one of the Trump supporters who was
shot by a trigger-happy cop
what about the rest of the story what
about the story about the cops being
murdered
Tucker's got tape on that too they're
killing several police officers in the
meantime but Brian sicknick should not
be reduced to a prop for the political
Ambitions of the democratic party he was
a human being the facts of his life
matter including how he died
to this day media accounts described
sicknick as someone who was quote slain
on January 6th the video we reviewed
proves that is a lie here is
surveillance footage of sicknick walking
in the capital after he was supposedly
murdered by the mob outside by all
appearances signic is healthy and
vigorous he's wearing a helmet so it's
hard to imagine he was killed by a head
injury
whatever happened to Brian sicknick was
very obviously not the result of
violence he suffered at the entrance to
the Capitol this tape overturns the
single most powerful and politically
useful eye the Democrats have told us
about January 6th and it was indeed a
lie the January 6 committee knew
perfectly well that Brian sicknick was
walking normally through the capitol
after he was supposedly murdered by
Trump supporters
there it is and the whole rest of the
Tucker report is terrific coincidentally
I actually happened to be on Tucker's
show
at the very end of the show when this
was going on and they had asked me to
come on the show to talk about all the
crazy defamation where the libs accused
me of genocide and they mentioned they
said Michael we really want to get the
story in but we might be a little tight
on time because we're doing a big
January 6th report I said I had just
forgotten about the tapes I said huh why
are why are you doing a January 6th
report on this March 6th and years later
and then because of this
because the same footage
can tell a completely different story
depending on who is constructing that
narrative
and the the great irony here is that
the lives use this one phrase they they
used a few phrases Insurrection and the
one phrase they kept using ever since
the 2020 election was the big lie this
was the the propaganda line that all of
the left-wing voices in the media in
politics they would all say it was the
big lie Trump and his supporters are
spreading the big lie
and they use that phrase because that
phrase is associated with Hitler and the
Nazis the irony is they don't realize
that that phrase
was actually used by Hitler to accuse
the Jews of telling a big lie about a
German general and World War one so if
you are using the phrase the big lie if
you were accusing someone of the big lie
you are putting yourself in the place of
the Nazis the Democrats not particularly
historically literate so that irony was
lost on them and then of course they
they harp on lie lie lie lie lie
who was who was putting forward such a
lie very often when people when the
Democrats in particular accuse
Republicans of something
you can you can take it to the bank that
the Democrats are probably doing that
themselves
and you can you can see this in the case
of January 6th there's more to come I
can see why Chuck Schumer is begging
Tucker please don't error please Rupert
Murdoch stop talker please Kevin
McCarthy stopped her stop them from
exposing what so many people knew from
the very beginning
was a show
it was a sh I don't I don't know how
else to describe it all the world is a
stage politics is a really big stage
people were presented with a fictional
narrative now that narrative is being
corrected and you will never see the
libs push back harder than when their
narratives fall apart that's why they
call people Nazis that's why they accuse
people of genocide that's why they say
the threats to democracy when you are
getting those threats made against you
when you were having those accusations
thrown at you you know you are hovering
right over the target
[Music]